music
I'm
not
Yeah.
Oh.
Hello.
Hello everyone.
Turn you guys down a bit.
My beautiful girls.
Yeah.
Can you hear everyone good?
Hello chat.
Hello.
Hi.
So, uh, change of plans.
Everything broke.
Yay.
Absolutely.
Everything broke.
And so now we're, we're doing a zatsu.
Woo.
Because then we tried to do a jack box and that wasn't working out and then, yeah, Uno
didn't want to fucking behave.
So we're here.
We're just going to chat.
Uh, we might do some like Q and A and then maybe do some like would you rather questions
or like will you press the button questions or just maybe we'll just tell each other really
bad pickup lines or try to raise each other up.
We spent like, what was it, like that first hour, hour trying to make this work.
And I'm so sorry everyone that it didn't work out.
Literally Ubisoft said you don't own Uno and I said, what do you mean?
It's right here.
Yeah.
I purchased it and did like family sharing from our other accounts and then to let me
had to buy it on our normal accounts and that still didn't work.
Well, it only worked for me and Emmy and Azura and then it just wouldn't open and then it
just nothing was working.
It was so dumb.
It was, it was not working.
You pressed play and it just closed it out again.
Yeah.
And I would literally just crash.
So I hate Ubisoft.
We all hate Ubisoft.
We all hate Ubisoft in this house.
That's why my, I thought it was annoying.
We paid twice.
And it still didn't work.
Yeah.
They're just trying to steal our money.
I can't wait to refund every game title from us.
We paid twice.
And it still didn't work.
Yeah.
They're just trying to steal our money.
I can't wait to refund every game title from them.
Sending the CEO a personalized letter.
I'm sending the CEO a seasoned assist.
It doesn't make any sense, but I'm doing it.
Um, but yeah, if you guys have questions for us, let's do, we'll do a couple of, would
you, uh, will you press the button questions and then you guys can come up with questions
and post them in our respective chats.
Um, and then maybe we'll read like one from each of our chats.
The questions are going to be like, did you guys have sex in real life yet?
When are you going to have sex in real life?
Not yet.
Soon.
Very soon.
Um, but yeah, that'll give you some time to think of questions to ask us.
Uh, let's see, let me find a good will you.
Should, I'm wondering if I should do this one.
Um, I don't think we want to be based right off the bat.
I do.
I'm going to send you guys a screenshot of the question it just asked.
I'm dying.
Oh God.
Here you go.
What, what is the screenshot?
It's in general.
Oh shit.
I'm not American.
I don't care.
Maybe not that one.
I'm not American, but.
Some Americans might get triggered.
A lot of people said no to that question.
They wouldn't press the button, which is funny.
Um, this one doesn't make any sense.
What though?
You will become an extremely attractive girl, but no guys will find you attractive.
That doesn't make any sense.
What?
Makes sense.
I would be extremely attractive.
I'm already an extremely attractive girl.
What's there to lose?
Oh, okay.
Here you go.
Would you, will you press the button?
If you could change the weather at will or the, but the weather you choose is last for
a month.
Oh, I will not press the button.
I think I just like rain a lot and I don't want it to rain for a month though.
Oh, I do.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I just like a lot and I don't want it to rain for a month, though.
Oh, I do.
Yeah, uh, you would?
I do want it to rain a month.
I thought, I thought I would be emo.
I thought you meant, I thought you meant like season.
I'm sour.
to be sunny you know no I want it I want the opposite now I mean I got a
basement so and all the senpais are there they'll all drown if like there's
too much rain but a month is so long yeah yeah you could have given fly the
pens the people are okay here's the next one you can revive and keep love
ones from dying but every time you use your powers 50,000 I feel like I'm
conflicted because I would just kill a senpai if I even suspect anything but
me who can already do that yeah but usually Emmys powers come with a sort of
twist no humans need to die no one needs to die everyone live I'm killing 50,000
people to bring back who to die though like 50,000 you want to use 50,000
people specifically like by name anyways oh that one was almost split
people put 45% and 55% said no great ethno cleansing from mercy over here
I'm joshing around I'm not joshing where you say is there what what should I
should we all do the poem do you know what where is this bowl oh I'm just
reading off the questions from the website you receive a diary that tells
you everything that happens in the future but you'll participate in a game where you have to be
hunted down by other diary users that can also see the future. Ooh that sounds like an anime.
Yeah right. Is it a anime? It should be. It should be. Is it a math book? Future diary? Yeah isn't it a
mirror anime game? Oh wait yeah that's wait that's fucking true actually.
I'm like why does it sound so familiar? I would do it. I would do it. It sounds fun.
And plus you have a diary and I would win. Yeah that's true. I feel like would you be
clever enough to outwit other diary users though? I mean outwit. We just killed them.
But they're gonna try to kill you too. They also have the diary. Yeah but I'll kill them first.
Okay. I'm not if I kill them first. I don't I think I would die so I won't I won't kill them.
You find five dollars but you give it back to the person who dropped it. What the fuck? No. No.
It's a five dollars is mine. Yeah. Yeah what the fuck. No maybe maybe I want to feel good for that
day and be like yeah I did something nice. You feel good by stealing five dollars.
Yeah exactly. Five finger discount. Get five dollars. Well mine if I do. Yeah. I wish I could
make a messy spot. I probably do it though. I mean like that's something I just do normal.
Okay stop being a good person. Yeah what does it look? I mean I'm a terrible person. So awful. I
think babies are gross and babies are gross and old ladies. I don't know if I can ask this word.
Ask it. Ask it. Ask it. You have the house of your dreams furniture etc all included
but it's in Somalia. What's wrong with Somalia? It's well specifically it's in
Mogadishu Somalia which is not a safe place. Oh I don't know anything about that place.
Okay ignore that one. I'll skip it. Yeah we'll skip that one. Pirates? Yeah sure.
Wow there's a lot of murderous questions. You save 10,000 people around the world
but you have to drown a person with your bare hands. Easy. Easy peasy. Yeah easy peasy. You've
already done that before. I'll just choose a senpai. Easy. Yeah someone that's a willing sacrifice.
Yeah yeah just easy. Oh this is well I mean it's not that hard to like sacrifice someone but I mean
yeah maybe yeah. Easy peasy. Why does everybody why is all these questions have to do with death?
What is this? This one has to do with the f***ing FIFA World Cup so I'm skipping it.
I don't know anything about FIFA. I'm sorry senpai. I'm sorry
pin pals. I'm sorry harems. I'm sorry bleeding hearts. I don't know anything about FIFA.
Me neither it's okay. You can listen to any song with perfect quality in your head at any time
but you must listen to a 30 second ad after each song. No. This is just Spotify.
Music. Except in your head. This is Spotify. This is the future. This is the Neuralink.
Yeah I was gonna say I'm like this is what you don't muskies trying to do. That's what he wants.
No. I would not. I wouldn't either. I wouldn't probably also because I don't really listen to music.
This is the most annoying thing. Yeah especially it's like that really like annoying ad voice like
try lexa pro. You don't want to break from the ads? Oh my favorite hatred of ads is like I
I can't believe I'm playing this game. Oh my gosh. And it's like a really big tiddied woman walking
in a line. Well man sacked on top of her or something.
Wait I think that one too the like giant one right? Yeah. I was like AO. Can you like slap
his head on this? How long was the ad? It was like 30 seconds. Yeah like 30 seconds.
This is a good one. You become a very famous celebrity but you cannot see your family or
loved ones often. Once a year for a few days Mac. Right button press button. Press press.
Press button press press press press press press. Yeah they're slapping.
I wasn't really sad without my parents I would be really sad without my mom.
I love my parents like I also love Amy's mom and Mercy's parents would be very hard
for me.
Yeah, like I love them very much and that's why if I'm moving I want to move close to
them close I don't maybe I'll stay close by but she's like I'm going across the world
I wouldn't care.
I know a lot of people don't have good relationships with their parents I mean like yeah it's not
a terrible relationship it's not like massively terrible it's just I don't understand what
you mean.
Moving with them can be hard.
You pay with your soul instead of with a rent.
Any person of your choosing will want to have sex with you but you will die in five years.
I'm not pressing the button this is already my reality.
Fun!
Like the person of my dreams are my step-punch.
I know yeah I love my hair I love entertaining my hair I don't want to die so no thank you.
I love my hair's face.
A lot of people said no to that.
You will never experience this is a good one for Amy.
You will never experience difficulty going to the bathroom again but you will never
remember whether you flushed or not.
This already happens to me!
Sure I'll press the button I already don't remember if I flushed.
Yeah I'd press it too.
Oh my gosh.
It's like muscle memory to flush no?
Yeah so who cares?
And then you're just hoping because what if you forgot that one time.
You're buying as long as you're not over at a friend's house.
So are you guys pressing the button?
Yes.
You don't have to press the button I'm already regular.
Mercy doesn't suffer with constipation like the rest of us.
I know she doesn't have irritable bowel syndrome or something.
I do have IBS just not that IBS.
Oh irritable bouncy boobies syndrome.
Okay so this is a good question.
Any children you have with your fans will be very beautiful but they'll be really really
dumb.
So if you your senpais had a child with your senpais they'd just be really dumb ass child
but they're you know.
I'm pressing the button because I'm kind of already dumb so it's like.
It's already gonna happen I'll push the button as long as that kind as long as that child
is kind and thoughtful a little stupidity is okay.
Hopefully they're not like that one character from the one book that accidentally kills
things because he's really dumb was like grapes of wrath I don't know.
Same author.
Forget it.
Yeah.
I hit the button.
I don't know.
Where's my sign?
It is.
Who's the one pushing it out?
Huh?
78% said they wouldn't push the button.
Yeah no.
Uh-uh.
I think stupidity can be fixed.
They can't.
Just look at her fan bases.
I don't know about that.
I could be fixed.
Yay!
There's a cure for a zure.
There's a hope for me.
Well this is a great question.
You find out vampires are real and you can become one live forever and use your vampire
powers to stop.
I don't know why it specifically says terrorists but sure.
Okay.
However.
Hero vampire got it.
You sparkle.
I don't want to sparkle.
You're one of those vampires.
Yes!
Let's do it.
I don't want to sparkle.
You don't want to sparkle.
You only sparkle in my eyes Azura.
That's not enough for me.
I don't think I need to sparkle.
Let's go.
I get super powers to chase down my senpai and I'm sparkled.
I'm literally already a goddess.
Why do I need to be a vampire?
Well, not all of us are goddesses here, Mrs. Zura.
Some of us want superpowers.
And to sparkle.
I'm just a fucking rabbit.
Well, you have powers.
What are you talking about, Evie?
Yeah, you have a magic book.
I want a vampire.
Yeah, but you're still like, we don't know how old you are.
You're ancient.
You're like immortal.
Yeah.
Not beating those 3,000-year-olds.
Keeping funny allegations.
I'm going to press it.
I would love to be the sparkling terror of the night.
I thought you were going to say sparkling terror.
Ooh.
You can turn invisible whenever you want for as long as you want.
But everyone forgets you ever existed until you become visible again.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, sure.
I'll press the button.
Impressive.
Yeah, I feel like that's easy.
It doesn't even affect you.
Because you're invisible.
Yeah, it doesn't really.
Unless you're like trying to tell somebody what's going on and then you turn invisible
and then they just don't know what you're talking about.
You're in a hostage situation.
They don't even remember that you turned invisible.
That's good, yeah.
Press the button.
That's it.
These questions are so dumb.
All we do is like death.
And like, you could kill somebody.
But I'm like, OK, I get it.
Everybody wants to kill someone.
Death is death.
It's a very tall deal.
What did I say?
Didn't I literally say that this is all these questions?
I'm so much deaf in it.
Yeah.
Can we get some questions from the audience then?
Does anybody have any questions for us?
Yeah, don't hold back.
Ask us your spicy questions.
Go crazy.
Yeah.
Go stupid.
Go crazy.
Go wild.
And then after that, we can do, like, would you rather?
OK.
Someone from my chat asked, who do you think
could do a handstand the longest?
Me.
Yeah, I would say Azura.
Why Azura?
Because she's the most athletic and muscle mommy
on the world.
Oh, that's true.
You're a Azura.
Azura, yeah.
Yeah, I'm a Azura.
Yeah.
She does that for fun.
She just walks around like that for fun.
That's why she's so muscly.
Muscly?
Her kids just smack her in the face.
That's the only annoyance.
I won't be able to see where I'm going.
Who would win a burping contest between the four of you?
Emmy.
I would say Emmy.
Really?
I mean, I mean, I can't, we could, we could go
because I could, I think I could do it.
Yeah, you want to go right now?
Let's do it.
Go right now.
Yeah.
I'm ready.
Azura, you go first.
Get ready to judge.
Yeah, you go first.
You go first.
You go first?
Yeah, you go first.
Okay, hold on.
That was weak.
That was pretty good.
Ratings, judges.
Please don't make yourself barf.
Please don't barf.
I'm the barf tuber here.
The median seems to be about four out of 10.
Oh, that was good.
Oh my God.
That was mine.
That was pretty good.
Should be like best two out of three.
It's so weak.
That's impressive.
That was pretty good.
Azura, your rebuttal.
Oh, shit.
I'm going to lose.
Maybe it is Azura.
Yeah.
My chat seems to think that Azura.
Yeah, Azura's winning.
Azura's best burp.
All right.
Well, that answers that question.
That answers that question.
That was pretty good.
Burpler.
Thank God.
Oh, wow.
These girls, these bitches are disgusting.
Oh, burping.
Oh, someone says you're all lightweight needs training.
Performance anxiety.
Okay.
I can't get it up when people are watching.
Yeah, I swallowed a bit of air and that's going to come back
up like a crazy burp.
I can't wait.
Please don't mute.
Don't mute.
Just go like, whoa.
That'd be perfect.
All right.
Does anybody have any questions from their chat?
Amir or Azura?
I don't see any, any, any chatters with questions?
Anyone?
Any bleeding hearts with questions?
My girls are so cute.
Someone just asked, have you ever gotten caught by anyone other
than your parents?
Shut up.
Suck my dick.
I don't have good questions.
Oh, here, if all the, if all the members of viewer had who's
the most dumb competition, who would be the, what would be
the final rankings?
Me.
Actually, me and Azura might be tied for that.
A dumbass?
No, dumb.
It depends on what, on what they're doing because like,
you know, like, fun facts, I think I see would lose for fun
facts, but they would, you know, like, it's like, here's a bunch
of facts, which, which.
You know, we're saying dumb, not dumb.
Oh.
I think maybe we're all equally in our own special way.
The dumbest would be she be.
I would like, I like most doming out of all of us.
Yes.
Me because of my kayfabe, but in action, I would, I honestly
think it'd be you or mercy.
Me.
Really?
Yeah.
Like if besides myself, I would say maybe in me or mercy.
We gotta have a dumb off now.
Yeah.
Well, I feel it.
Well, then I saw my mommy voice and everything freaks out.
Feel like all of us have our own sterness in the way.
Open your mouth.
Shut up, you good girl.
All right.
So good at taking it off.
Thank you, mommy.
Be a good girl for me.
And do as she says.
If you're bad, I might have to spank you.
Slick, slick, slick, slick, slick.
Squish, squish, squish, squish, squish.
Grab a water bottle and just like.
The chat is spamming the step on me email.
Someone asked, wait, is there a, do you have one in your chat?
Yeah, there's our individual questions.
Okay.
I think questions for all four of us would be good too.
Well, we can answer too.
Someone has a question for mercy.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Someone has a question for mercy.
If you, if you had a, if you had a chance to design an outfit for someone and BLR, who
would you design one for?
I've already designed all of you guys.
Yeah.
She did, she did, she did outfits for all of us.
I think, I still think like all of them are super cute.
So if anyone wants to do art of them.
Oh, someone said, who do you think is the most degen of the four?
Degen.
Stronger.
Um, I think a lot of us hide our power level from each other.
I think it's strong.
They say out of the, I think all of you might be four of us.
Oh, out of the four of us, the four of us, the four of us might be in me.
If I was in another form, I might, uh, I think it's in me.
It means the degen, but I think it's me.
I got to keep classy being, being mad.
Um, although just wait for my hentai tag to remember stream.
People are going to be like, oh, canceled.
So I said, uh, who is the strongest drinker out of all four of us?
Not me.
I don't drink.
Uh, yeah.
Mercia doesn't like to drink.
So you don't drink.
I think that probably ended up being me.
How much do you drink a zero?
I was, yeah, I feel like a zero could take you.
How much do you drink?
Three, three to four bottles of soju.
Of soju?
I don't know.
So I'll have like one bottle of soju and halfway through it.
I'm already gone.
I don't know how much I drink, but if I want to have fun, I'll
have like a whole bottle of Baileys.
Why are you blushing at me?
Is something the matter?
Matter.
I, I, yeah, I don't drink.
And I'm, I, if when I do drink, I'm super lightweight.
So, yeah.
They're so probably in the super drunk audio, like a one drink.
Uh, huge sips and I'm gone.
Yeah, but all the fucking medication I'm on, I'm done.
Someone said you could squirt the farthest.
Next question.
Thank me.
I'd probably say all of the girls is like abilities, you know, I
don't know.
I can, I can, when I'm trying and I'm like in the shower, I
feel like I can piss pretty far.
If I had the force, wait, wait, was there a question about
how did this happen?
Like a score is essentially pissed just like whatever, but
I feel like Amy would squirt the most.
Oh, excuse me, sorry.
And then I would squirt the farthest.
Okay.
Yeah, maybe we should have a contest for this too.
Yeah.
Yeah, we'll try that out.
Okay, ready?
I think that goes so hard that it's over in less than like
two seconds and probably out of everyone.
I go to idol meetings the most.
You think so?
Oh, yes.
You could be a lot like once a day.
She go to a bathroom like every like five minutes.
You got a small bladder.
Pissing all by herself.
I gave her the crown of toilet queen.
She's the toilet queen.
She's regular toilet queen stuff, but pissing.
That's another story.
We really are.
I just, I drink a lot of water.
So that's good.
You're hydrated.
My piss is like highlighter yellow.
So I'm going to get some water.
My girl needs to drink more.
Yeah, drink more.
I drink a lot of water.
Mine is pretty clear, but I have an issue with getting up
and going to the bathroom.
I just sit here for a long time having to pee for like hours.
You don't like pee?
I would.
There's so many things I'd rather be doing than peeing.
So I'm just holding my pee for really long time.
I love pissing.
I hate peeing.
I just go.
I'm like, yeah, just go.
I need an iron break.
Yeah.
If you need to go, just go.
I hold it.
I got stuff to do in this thing.
Yeah.
Right.
I agree.
She be.
And sometimes it's my excuse to get out of out of a situation.
Yeah.
Like if I want to do something, I'll just go to the bathroom
for like an hour.
I think I'm used to it.
I think I'm used to it because I would play games.
Like, like, like, that requires you to not get up.
So you got to be, you got to like kind of hold it in.
It's the gamers that don't like to piss because they don't want
to be interrupted.
Exactly.
Azura doesn't want to piss between League games.
I can't piss between matches.
Hey, I didn't say what game.
I didn't say what game.
You have to say what game.
We know.
We know which one.
Come on, guys.
Give us some questions.
Exposing my chat.
Someone asked who's the craziest.
Oh, wait, wait, I have a question here.
Okay, okay.
What is one horror character you think you could take in a fight?
Pyramid head.
I'm sucking them all.
I'm sorry.
That was impossible.
I don't even know where that came from.
Whoa.
I didn't even think that just literally just hit me like a
like a stroke.
I was like, oh my God.
I'm understandable.
All of them might just get really big and step on them.
Brahms from the movie The Boy.
I'm sucking him off too.
Oh, a hundred percent.
Oh my gosh.
Get out of my walls into my bed.
Horror guys are like, most of these horror creatures are like
immortal and I'm just a cute girl.
Oh, Jason.
Oh, no, please.
There's just an issue.
I don't know.
Oh, Freddie Krueger.
Stop.
Oh.
No, no, whatever will I do?
It has nothing to do with horror anymore.
I'm sorry.
As long as it's not Godzilla, I'll take, I'll take him.
I don't think I can take on Godzilla.
I think I'll take him.
If we could take on anybody.
Yeah.
Does that count as horror?
You would step around.
I'm just like, just step around.
That was a good question.
I would win again.
Maybe I would like team up with all of them.
Oh, okay.
You're teaming up with all of them?
Yeah, like, you know, we, we go.
I didn't know Mercy would like that.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Nothing.
Don't worry about it.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, what?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Next question.
Does nobody have anything?
In a hunger game setting, who is the winner?
I see.
I see?
I feel like she'd destroy us.
She's a feral polar bear.
That's true.
I was thinking Azura because she can get big.
Yeah, but she's too sweet.
She doesn't want to hurt her creation.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
I would say it's down between I see and Mercy.
I don't want to hurt the babies.
I hurt my girls, but if I have to.
If you have to.
I'll do what I must.
Okay.
Someone in my chat asked something, too.
Oh, will you all ever do an NSFW collab?
Like, in what context?
Like, what context, though?
But yeah, like, generally, yeah.
They didn't get a collab.
I'm guessing Patreon.
Yes.
Yeah, oh, 100%.
Yeah.
Wait for a video game to come out.
People forget we have an NSFW game coming out.
The art.
Oh, boy.
I want to ask.
Someone asked what meal or food could be your only meal
for the rest of your life?
Your cum.
Oh, my God.
Give me your peepee.
You have to say something like, yeah,
I can probably eat sushi for the rest of my life.
I don't know.
I can't do that.
No, I can't do that.
That's torture.
I don't want to answer that question.
I could probably go with curry for the rest of my life.
I would say it was any sort of rice dish.
Like, if you could eat rice or pasta for the rest of your life,
I'd probably pick rice.
Probably rice.
Yeah.
Rice.
Rice, rice.
Yeah, rice.
Oh, is the video game going to be voice?
Yes.
How much will the game cost?
Yeah.
It's free, motherfucker.
It's free.
You get to do awesome stuff that I'm not going to reveal yet.
For free.
We'll suck you for free.
Oh, now I'm like blushing.
What is there to blush about?
Don't ask.
It's like, it's like, it's so intimate.
That's true.
You are on somebody with your,
your scissors in their face while you,
you know, ride them cowboys.
Very intimate.
So it's cool.
Who can do the best impersonation of any ViaLore streamer?
Chibi.
Chibi is just impersonation in general.
Yeah.
I'm going to get better.
After watching the haul live debut of Elizabeth Bloodflame,
I'm like, I got to get on her level, man.
Although she's like professional voice actress,
but it is what it is.
I want to be that level.
I'm waiting for Chibi to do Mercy's laugh.
Yeah, do Mercy.
Wait, what's Mercy?
Do your laugh.
Yeah, Mercy go first.
Excuse me.
Now I'm shy.
Now I've got performance anxiety.
Oh my God.
You can do it.
Someone say a charm.
Penis.
I think I just coughed instead.
Well, she cut out.
Yeah.
And then is there a talk?
Sample sentence.
Give us, give us something mommy.
I love all my babies.
It's really close.
I know.
I'm trying.
There's a tone to it.
Give yourself a lisp and it'll work.
I can't, but like, I, it's weird,
but I can't hear a lisp for you.
You don't have a lisp.
It's there.
To me, you don't have one.
I have one.
I have a lisp.
It's definitely there.
The tiniest lisp.
It's definitely not funny.
More like an accent to me.
Yeah, it feels like an accent.
Yeah.
It's more like a controlled lisp.
A controlled lisp.
I have to work around it so people can understand me.
It's already hard enough for people to understand me.
We can understand you just fine.
Yeah, I know you.
Yay.
I'm happy.
I'm beautiful.
Like, honestly, I haven't been able to do Emmy's voice.
I can't do Emmy's voice.
I'm just too, I'm just too good.
I'm just too original.
Whoa.
It's like, I, I feel like I can only do one, like,
funny voice.
I like, I like Emmy's, I like Emmy's laugh
because she sounds like Timo.
I sound like Timo?
I don't know what Timo sounds like.
League.
Oh, do you remember when the fucking voice lines
I sent in chat one time when we were recording lines
for the trailer?
Yeah.
And Zara asked me to voice Timo.
I'm like Timo.
Like Timo laughing or just like Timo in general?
You sound like Timo laughing.
No, you sound like Timo in general.
Oh, fuck.
I'm going to go listen right now.
Timo's voice.
Oh, it's an ugly fucking furry too.
Timo's known as Lil Satan.
Like people, people don't like that character.
Yeah, I've never played Lil Satan in my life.
Lil Satan?
Wow.
Yeah.
Who does that remind you of?
Do a line.
Do a Timo line.
Um, hold on.
Let me listen.
I've already played Timo lines for a while.
Arden ready.
That's got it.
That's got a sting.
I've already done Timo lines for a zero and for my chat.
I played it for them the ones I recorded.
Did it work?
Did it sound like Timo?
Did it?
It was a furry confirmed.
Oh God, you nailed it.
Yay!
I could just be Timo.
So cute.
I love you.
I love all my girls.
Should we do a Peter Griffin voice?
I'm a scout ahead.
Zara's dying.
I think she's fangirling over League's stuff, maybe.
She's gone.
Yeah, she's happy.
Her voice is so cute.
Wait, is it League on your Steam library?
Yeah.
Yeah, well I have.
Yes, I do have League.
Everybody's downloaded League sometime in their life.
I now love League and then immediately got sick after it.
I was overwhelmed from the hood.
Hey, Peter, nice cat.
Hey, Peter, nice cock.
Peter.
There's a horse.
The horse is cute.
Peter.
Jo and Quagmire's in there.
That's the dumbest shit I ever heard, Peter.
That was pretty good.
Is that a Zara?
That's the dumbest shit I ever heard, Peter.
I can't tell.
Who was that?
I know, because nobody's mouth is moving.
Sorry, that was me.
Zara can do good impressions too, that's for sure.
She also has the same voice range as me.
Oh yeah, that's true.
Everyone has such a good voice range and I'm just like, where am I?
Here.
You're fine.
You have a beautiful voice.
You're cute.
You have beautiful voices.
I cum every time.
I mean, I'm cummin.
You're coming?
What?
No, cummin, cummin.
In my mouth?
You're cummin?
Yeah.
Yeah, cummin.
Yeah, I'm cummin.
I thought it was cummin.
Shut up.
Is it coming?
I don't know, man.
Cute and funny Zara.
Yeah, she can do a cutie voice.
I think you can do like a cute, cutie voice.
Yeah.
We did one yesterday, not yesterday.
A couple days ago in our collab.
You switched to it randomly.
Yeah.
When you're like happy.
I do.
I don't know.
I mean, Zara both do that.
Don't do that.
I don't like it.
You turned it up perfect.
We're all cute and funny at heart.
I think they have great cute and funny voices.
My voice isn't cute.
It's ugly.
Oh, she's so cute.
Such a trashy.
Is he?
Mine just sounds like a really annoying like anime dub.
Is he ugly?
My cat is.
Oh, don't worry.
Yeah, don't worry.
Sorry, I'm chewing an airhead.
It's okay.
Never underestimate the power of the scout's code.
What the fuck?
Someone just asked me to say that.
Can you all do cute and funny voices for two minutes?
Oh my God.
Cute and funny challenge?
Okay.
Well, you're...
You don't...
You have to do a mature voice.
Yeah, you have to do a mature voice.
Hold on, hold on.
I have to get more water.
I'll be right back.
You guys talk.
Never underestimate the power of the scout's code.
Okay, that's really good.
Why are we all talking like that?
Because we're doing a cute and funny challenge.
Oh, okay.
Are we doing a cute and funny challenge?
I guess I'll do it too.
Yeah.
And then I don't want anyone to get mad at me and tweet.
I don't care.
It's whatever.
I didn't tweet at all.
I just forget.
Never underestimate the power of the scout's code.
Scout's code.
Why scout's code?
Wait, hold on.
I need to make myself smaller.
No, I'm cute and funny.
I'll just hide my chest.
Now I'm short.
Now I can read your BP easier because I'm eye level with it.
Sorry, what?
Could you repeat that?
What's the funniest thing you've read recently?
Your tweets.
Get a fucking life loser.
Oh my God.
I'm in biting range.
Give me your fucking ankles.
Give me some wiggles.
I'm the kuzugaki now.
Water in the cage.
You guys are in my bedroom.
Oh, everyone's in my bedroom too.
So I could put you guys on the cage.
I can also, I'm perfect height to sniff in me.
If either of you could work on a song with the favorite band or artist, who would it be?
Doja Cat!
I hate cops.
No, that was so quick.
Because I'll be fucking sick.
I've been talking this whole time and I've been muted.
Fuck.
The whole stream?
No, like a couple of years ago I was talking with you guys and I was muted.
How did you even mute yourself?
Well, because I went to get more water so I muted my mic.
Oh, that's right.
And then I forgot to unmute.
You were going to do your mommy vlog.
Yeah, she definitely forget to flush the toilet.
I didn't go to the bathroom.
I just got more water.
I was here.
Can you give your best mommy impression?
I don't have a mommy voice.
That's the problem.
Everyone always assumes like, oh, she can do cunny voice.
So that means she can do mommy voice too.
You could just go real deep.
Why do you sound country?
Our country voice.
Go real, real deep, real deep.
Yo, what's up?
Welcome to Alabama.
K-Y-S.
Hey, kiss your fucking sister, brother.
Alabama.
Get over here.
I don't know about that one.
That's it.
Alabama.
Hey, y'all.
My name, Bubba Gooddick.
And I give Bubba good play.
Bubba good play.
Yeah, y'all.
Save a boy.
Just ride a cowboy.
Roll time.
Save a horse.
Ride a cowboy.
I don't know what the fuck this is,
but this is the first ASMR stream I've been on.
Brother, in what world are we doing ASMR?
Bring out this show, please.
Someone asked me, Christ.
Which of the seven deadly sins is your sin of choice and why?
Why?
Gluttony.
For him me.
I want you.
Maybe, you know, I might, maybe envy.
Oh, envy too.
Because I use envy as a motivation for myself sometimes,
because I'm like, I want to do this.
Cry.
Or wrath, yeah, or wrath.
I do have anger issues sometimes.
I know wrath.
Wrath is definitely like my anger issues.
Yeah.
I'm like, let me just break everything.
Lust is pants.
Lust is all of ours.
Yeah.
Me and me.
We're all lost.
Why would we break it up?
I think I definitely have a lot of wrath in me.
And it comes out.
What?
I'm just lazy.
I'm a lazy bitch.
So slow.
So am I, yeah.
Oh, you don't need to break things.
You have us for that.
Yeah, but you're not like physically in front of me,
or I'd be beating the shit out of you right now.
Beat your goddess.
And give her your soul.
I just love watching Azura's expressions.
Her freeze tracking is superb.
I don't know what it is.
I think all of us have like equal face tracking.
It's just some of us are more.
I would end to extreme deaths to like really make the face
a little tracking fix.
Like, oh my face.
Some of us have, what's it called?
V.C. face?
Or V. Bridger?
V. Bridger.
Some of us, I see has V. Bridger in her, in her,
in her rigging, but I don't know if I do.
V. Bridger.
Am I rigging?
Yeah.
I see does.
You might.
Yeah, you might.
I do.
I saw, I see those.
I didn't see it in my, in my rigging files.
I don't know.
Oh, interesting.
But that's a story for another day.
That's a story for another day.
I will never tell.
Yeah, strong because all that story.
What?
I hate.
Really?
Seriously?
Are you serious?
Seriously what?
Was Azura's pancake burnt or not?
They were burnt.
They weren't burnt!
They weren't burnt.
They were burnt.
I'm sorry.
I'm really proud.
Cookie bear, sweetheart, sugar, pumpkin,
pumpkin pie.
Those were burnt.
No!
Burn.
I'm sorry, sweetie.
What fucking pancakes are we talking about right now?
No one that Azura posted.
You know, the one with the butter on top.
And you think I would call Azura's other pancakes a burnt?
You know.
I don't know.
God damn.
That's some black on black crime.
They weren't burnt.
It was just the lighting.
I swear.
More questions.
Hand them over.
Grabby hands.
I had one but I lost it.
I lost all my questions too.
You know, if it is ginger,
am I strawberry blonde?
I guess so.
I think you're just blonde.
Wait.
I'm still salty about that.
I'm not fucking ginger, dude.
I thought you were redder.
You were redder in your life changing.
You're redder in your concept art.
Yeah.
But your model is lighter blonde hair.
Oh, wow.
But then I have like,
then I'm ginger at the ends.
Although I don't know if my hair is dyed.
Why are you bouncing right now?
I would call yours a sunset.
I would call your hair sunset.
What are you saying?
A sunset gradient.
Mercy's attempted at Riz.
Your hair is like
the rays of a sunset.
Okay, sorry.
What were you going to ask?
Someone asked what do you guys plan on doing
if you get 3D models?
Dance.
Yeah, pretty much.
Do you have a bunch of poses?
Work.
Pull dancing.
We want to do pull dancing.
Oh yeah, we did talk about pull dancing.
Like a potential pull dancing,
and all of us fail,
or at least me fail.
I want to get a lot of fuck you money
so that we can get our own studio.
That would be so sick, our own 3D studio.
That'd be insane.
I mean, we all meet up
and pull dance together.
We thought about doing like classes, right?
Yeah.
I'll call it a pull.
That'd be so fun.
Yeah!
And then they're like fun.
Probably like,
I would just stream regularly with a 3D model.
People don't know how,
I move so much.
My tail.
Yeah, we talk with our hands.
Yeah, we're very animated.
So.
Now we can only talk with our hips.
Yeah.
And our tits.
You talk with your hips.
Be the Helen Keller and talk with your hips.
Hips don't lie, you know?
I'm very kind of like un-flexible,
so like I think it'll be very funny to see me pull it.
I'm un-flexible, too.
Yeah, it'd be funny trying to pull myself up on something.
You'll actually see how little upper arm strength I have.
And he's trying.
I think it would be,
I think it'll be really funny.
Someone said if you could pick who would,
if you could pick who would you swap outfits with in Villalor?
Mercy.
Yeah, Mercy.
You wanna wear my outfit?
Yeah, it's really cute.
You're very cute.
I'm very much like the aesthetic of Mercy
and Amy's emo outfit.
I really like him.
I would also be a totally goth mommy.
I know Azura would, too.
We all like goth mommy, too.
Literally my entire closet is pretty much goth clothes,
so it'd be so funny if two point-os
if we all just had like a goth model.
I think it's so funny that like all these girls dress so cutely
and then I'm like, I just like this for my senpai's
and then you see a while you're just like big giant t-shirt.
Yeah, I just have like big giant t-shirt.
I go out, I wear my sweater,
my hoodie, my oversized hoodie with leggings
and blend in.
I like to go all out when I go outside sometimes.
Oh, they're so beautiful.
And then I see could be pastel goth.
Should be cute and good.
I was thinking like I could do like,
if we do like a two point-o,
I'd be like some kind of G-R-I-K.
I was thinking that, yeah, 100% for you, G-R-I-K.
I was like re-think,
because after you guys did your like design streams,
I was like, oh, what would I draw you guys as?
And I was definitely thinking G-R-I-K for you.
I would definitely love if I have like a updated two point-o.
I would love to do like some G-R-I-K or something.
I would probably just go,
I don't even know what I would do.
I think, I think, oh, it would be really nice
if you had like a very, very mermaid skirt.
Mermaid?
Aquatic bunny here.
I just turned into like a sea bunny.
That would be cute.
Like those little sea slugs.
Like those little funny guys, right?
Yeah.
That would be so adorable.
Zero looks very suspicious.
Her expression.
She's drinking her boba.
And it's really funny watching her.
Oh.
She looks like she got caught doing something suspicious.
Whatever do you mean?
Wait, can you go drink something again?
Because we look angry while you do it.
That's funny.
Looks like she's going to start talking shit.
I love salt powder.
Like, all right.
I can't drink.
Someone said,
if you could visit anywhere in the world,
where would it be?
These questions are boring.
Ask something intense.
Your house.
Your fucking bed.
Like, I don't know.
Your dad's bed.
I probably didn't ask Ronnie to be honest.
Sonny actually loves.
Like come on,
come on.
Give me some spicy questions.
Yeah.
What are these questions?
Spicy questions.
I'm not answering the poop question.
Okay.
There's a poop question.
Which of you could throw Amy the farthest?
Me.
I would say, yeah,
Azora.
Azora then me.
Especially if she grows giant.
Yeah.
Okay.
Who in your eyes has the most intense fans?
I see.
Yeah.
Her.
Her daughter.
How about out of the four of us?
Out of the four of us.
Out of the four of us, then Amy.
Amy.
And everybody,
I'm telling you,
when people just get a whiff of that cute and funny,
they go, they go feral.
They go feral.
To me,
Amy has probably
very interesting fans.
You also did.
Girl,
you scared me the other day
when I saw what you did
to your toy
on the ritual.
I was like,
oh,
okay.
And I'm going to tell you guys right now,
you pin pals out there.
You're fucked, bro.
You're never getting rid of her.
Some of them were like,
why does my penis hurt now?
You did like some mass casting and I'm not even you guys are cooked. I'm so sorry
Yeah, you're gonna be dreaming of her you're gonna be oh man, you are gonna be madly in love with Amy if you're not
We have a question oh
If you could spend a day in she bees be the awesome dungeon, what would you let she be do to you?
Anything she wants to I would probably I'll tell you what I'll do to each of you
For Azura, I'd probably strap her down to something and get one of those automatic toys
Just a whale on her and just walk away and be like have fun
for Amy
I
For Amy I mean Amy loves to be loved and cherished and I would whisper sweet nothings to her while I punch her into the gut
And then I'd also be strapping something to her
Bottom half so that she can buzz with excitement as I do so and then for
Then for Mercy
Mercy you said you like grik, right
You know I might do like knife play mercy
Well that you know we do something with that I'm not gonna elaborate
I
Definitely get some shabari ropes on her
I feel like she would like getting a taste of her own medicine
What she does to her son?
She's back. Hold on. I gotta move
Are you okay?
What do you mean is this what you want
You're not entertained. I can't even like there's like a constant like notification pop popping up. That's weird
Not the technical difficulties even
Please
Please this won't go away. I keep pressing. Okay, and it won't go away. What program?
To the
Yeah
What's it there or so I sense it in general
Doing mid mid
It won't go away
No, we're that it cuz you're obviously connected
There's fighting for her life. Okay. Okay
Hypothetically if VLR had an HR department, who would be the best HR person
Out of all of us, I guess out of all of us
Maybe mercy
probably me I
Feel like we need definitely not strongy
Definitely
What what me argue your reasoning why you
I'm gonna be bossy and I'm gonna tell you guys you can't do things
Because I have some HR experience I would say myself
Experience and not even lower wise just like me
So I say myself, but I think like that we don't have HR because we don't fucking need one
Yeah
We're all we're all adults
Sex pest allocation
Johnny's not beating the sex Johnny would be it would get sent to HR
Oh, yeah, he would constantly be going to HR from from complaints. Oh
Somebody asked what would
What would we each do to each other with our respective niches just didn't like kind of in the same frame that I did if you guys were in my dungeon
Okay, I guess just trap all of you
Trap trap trap trap trap trap all of you
I'll make you all
My happy happily ever after life and if you ever deviate from it, it's over
Yeah, but like like like like naughty
Oh, she's probably starting
I guess I guess, you know, I guess, you know
Maybe a little maybe if I could be a little forceful
You're so cute about it, I guess if I could be a little bit forceful
She says as she shoves something up our asses
I wouldn't mind
Yeah
There's just a disembodied voice
You know, I might I might I might like hold your hand
Oh, you're gonna talk talk me through it. You know, yeah, and and be like so gentle. Oh, maybe even kiss me on the cheek a little bit
Yeah, kiss on the cheek and pat your head a
Lot of eye contact
As I look at your one eye
I can take it off
We're getting really hot in here. Yeah, I'm feeling a bit toasty
Now like you have like an actual sweat drop
She's turning down. Yeah
Amy, what about you? Okay, I'll go one by one. What if I was your big sister?
What would you do to your big sister? I'll start with Mercy. I want to hear Mercy's reaction. Okay
Mercy, you know, I feel like
Mercy I feel like I would I would blindfold her and
and
I would maybe maybe I would use some some tools that she's familiar with on her and I'd maybe make her guess what I'm using
Does she get punished if she guesses wrong? Oh, of course she does
Oh
For she be I feel like I feel like some some office role play would be fun. Maybe maybe I could be like a
My little secretary. Yeah, you're a little secretary
And I'll accidentally drop some paperwork on on the ground
Then dover slowly you better be wearing a skirt
I'll be wearing a skirt. Maybe not something underneath the skirt though. Oh
I'm getting I'm getting real excited right now
I'm here. I'm I'm like if you check mine like my
My uh
My strum my stream you see I'm like everything's fine. I fixed it
Yeah, I'm cutting out for me. It's okay. I can hear you Azura. Yeah, you're fine. Yeah, you're fine. Yeah
Am I am I there for everyone else?
Why would you do Azura that's a hard one
I feel like for Azura, I'd actually like to court her first a little take her to a nice dinner
I would not stand stand her up at the dinner. I would I would I would drive her there
I would pick her up from her house and
And then afterwards I don't believe that you can drive but
And then afterwards I would I would maybe you know have prepared some candles and some petals on the bed
I'll take it real slow and nice with Azura
Okay, all right
Wait, wait, can I can I get a little bit of that niceness, too?
Everybody wants to be pampered
Not me oh
Oh, oh, I don't want to be pampered
Well, maybe
Because if anything I'm definitely not going to be nice to you guys
Yeah, don't worry about it. She just needs a couple of love taps every now and then
She didn't say she doesn't want to be treated gently, I guess
But I don't think I'd be very gentle with any of you
I want to be ungodly things to mercy. Yeah, I'll sit in the cook chair to watch that
I
Want to hold her down. I want to see her make all the
She'll make you know, she's very expressive. So, you know, she'll make faces I
Want to make her draw oh my god, and I want her to scream
I
Got a shift my legs a little bit. What's going on?
Mercy has left
Simply deceased
Oh my god, oh my god
I love I love eliciting reactions from mercy
You mean eat out
On my tongue
What did you just say
Repeat it say it again speak up
Big and twirl mercy around on my tongue
You could see my actual face right now
What would you do in me? Oh, yeah, I
I
Want to spank you I feel like you're like the biggest brat ever
And you deserve to get spanked. You need to behave bad and me
To those poor humans you need to be spanked
I
Wouldn't chat is agreeing with you
Yeah, definitely emmy emmy's definitely the the brat and I see has become the princess
It's cute. I love I like the switch
Azura out doming she be confirmed. Listen
Don't get it twisted. No, he's being a mom disciplining you. Yeah, he's being like she's mine has no love behind
Unless I say so I'd add love behind it and I would she be
Me no, I mean Azura would fight for dominance we would we would I have a lot of fun doing it
She's gone for a jog
All right
Sorry, I'm cool. Oh good. Oh good. Yeah, I understand
That's like so so effective. It's her voice
I
Want to see what she looks like died up. I mean, we're already looking at her
She's
Too spicy for you two right now. Okay. Um, do you have any other questions? I
Saw someone ask a question, but it might be too much for YouTube. I don't know. Let me look for it again
Oh
Like our hair moves
Here's a question. I'll copy and paste it to chat and you guys can let me know if you're okay with answering that
Okay, okay
I would say
Me I can tell you that it's not me. I'd say it's me
She matches your freak I
Think it's definitely not me. I'm so I'm so vanilla. I'm sorry out of everybody. It's straw knee
Yeah, I feel like it would be a zero a zero. What does a zero own? That's so exotic. I don't know but I just she's hiding
Okay, okay, but you're fighting so much again. Yeah, I know that's why I'm like what she has a whole closet full
I assure you
I guess me on the on on the outside, but is there a deep down
She be owns it
As there is deflecting, you know, I don't know what you're talking about
I am the goddess of the lore
I am an angel
Fallen angel
Yeah, I don't I don't think there's anything angelic about this goddess
What are their questions you guys see any questions?
I'm surprised the yandere has the weakest sense
I don't know what they mean by sets, but like I think that's
They said sets like S E T S like exercise sets like at the gym
toy sets
I have snoopy parents
That's true. My mom does the same thing every time she comes over
She opens my fucking closet and goes through my clothes because she's like oh did you buy any new clothes and
Literally right behind my clothes in my closets is my box full of sex
I'm like, oh my god, please don't look at that box. Please don't notice the box
Honestly, I'm very nosy. I'm very vanilla. It's like if something looks too scary. I'm just like
I think I really am the most exploratory up in here. Yeah, you're she's silent, but deadly
She's gonna talk about it. She's just show it off. But like a zero is a killer. I'll tell you that I
I
Don't care. I don't let my mom go through any of my things. Oh fight her. Oh
You got stuff to hide. Oh, you have stuff to hide. I
Have like a bunch of outfits like
Collars have like
Sets I have like a closet full. I don't let my mom go on any of my stuff
Oh, and then she'll just take it out and then she'll be like
And I'm like
So go and she'll tell people so even probably take a picture in and make fun of me
Oh my god, everybody look my daughter fucks
Even I was doing like a little cosplay she came into my room one time because I forgot to lock the door and then she went out
Because she had guessed over and she went out and she was like, oh my god
She's doing cosplay come come show them come show them for I was like in the most skimpiest shit
You don't understand
What were you wearing
A
YouTube doesn't like this one. I don't think we should talk about that
Obviously show us just tell us what the new cosplay does. Mm-hmm. Don't show us. It's okay. Um, okay, let me see if I have any questions
Everybody's just freaking out because of Zara everyone's saying no wonder you press so hard on
Yeah
Yeah, I have no privacy, I have no privacy so everything I have is like very
Small
Anyone breath any of us broke the law. Yeah, I walked before
I broke the law. What did you do?
public
What's it called public exposure? She probably was like
herself in the woods
Probably did leave herself on the chain
I've never broken the law I've gone spoken to because I've broken to
An abandoned mansion before with my friends
Oh, that's so fine because there's one right near my like high school graduation party
So I was literally like, oh, what the fuck's this and we just wanted it was cool. Then we got scolded but that was like
I was like 17
Think of some laws I broke I drove
Faster than speed limit, but did you get caught?
No
It doesn't count
J walked across the street
What's the favorite audio you've recorded so far I
Likeed my armpit audio the most because I feel like I'm not really good at acting subby
I feel like my audio is where I act more dominant. I feel more comfortable. So that's my favorite
When were you fucking lick the sweat off of my armpit while you're dorking it?
I like the Amazonian one
Oh
The what?
Amazonian
Oh my
Is that an upcoming one?
No, it's one that already came out
Check it out
My favorite hasn't come out yet. It won't come out for a few months
I did a nice
The job of blow audio that I was very proud of
Um, I guess my first audio
Really?
Was like the one that I was really proud of just like my my first time and I was like
Which is probably
The second one that came out was my first one
I'm surprised I'm not burping as much as you guys in this video
Someone said
What's your high score for doing it in a single day probably Newton and tootin minds eight
Yeah, mine's also eight
Wait, what?
Tootin Newton
How many times you jorked and orked in a day?
Like Newton tootin? I was like like how many times I farted in a day?
No, no
How many times did you did you finish the race?
Oh
In a single day
Like all they're just asking it like in one day like how many and one day I
Thought they were last I'm like overall no in in one day didn't count
You didn't tell sorry for the BGM jumpscare. I don't count. I don't count
I'm just gonna type it in you came 20 times in a day. Hey, ain't no fucking way. Ain't no fucking way
Ain't no fucking way
Tiring I wouldn't be able to go looks to continue. Yeah, like I'm tapping out
You take breaks, but like you're doing it in one day 20 like
24 hours, that's one one each hour
That's like 18
Get some food
I don't understand what you said mercy
It's a fanzly endurance stream
Wait, let me see
What do you get it?
No, hold on. Let me just read it it but like you do it
Like oh back-to-back. Oh it keeps going. I understand that feeling. I know exactly what you're talking about
Even if you have only ones it's not like if you're doing it multiple
I don't know
I think she means the entire time the entire time the entire
You do it once and then just continues
She's good the entire day happen. I have that happen before I am
What's the longest what's the longest one of yours have lasted? Oh, I don't know I
Say for me like two minutes
Yeah
That can't be humanly possible
No, they're having me question my own body. I'm confused
No, I just never I I've never experienced that
Yeah, I mean either like being high but a different kind of high like post not clarity or whatever, but like
Like the jitters and you you keep it for quite at some time because I understand like sensitivity
Yeah, afterwards and like continuing
There's just like yeah, I constantly have a vibrate in my panties and that's how I do it
She went to heaven and stayed there
Yeah, I feel bad for guys they can't experience like a lot maybe a max like maybe like three
Mm-hmm
I must suck sucks to be a man can't relate
Katora supremacy. I'm actually one more. I I I actually wish I had a I had one
Yeah, you why I would just like to stick it in things
I'd like to stack donuts on it. Yeah
I want one
I'm so jealous like
The bliss of just having one and then no like extreme mess. You could put it places
No, you could do so much with it and I think I might hook up that the sensitivity
But our sensitivity is more than that
That's not true. Not unless you go for the g spot
Wait, oh you want to put it in the butt
All right, uh food
Um everybody's very
Very scared
Not an ominous laugh at all an evil
Yeah, I would just I would just want to know like what textures would be like with that
Isn't it true that like uh dudes can taste like alcohol with their balls or something?
They can like
Dip them in like soy sauce. Yeah, what was it? Yeah, I heard of that myth
Yeah, is that a thing like or bitter things? Is that true? Everybody is saying no. Yeah, I don't think it's true
You know the internet lied to me then
Okay, one said it's true. Okay. Uh, haram members. I need you to go dip your balls in soy sauce
Please report back to us
Yep and report back you you should be tasting in the back of your mouth
Yep, I mean you're not doing that. You can't disobey me. Go fucking do it
Take a video so we did it. Yeah, take a video
Listen to your madam if you do it as she says I'll reward you with an audio of me cleaning them off
Oh my
I'm gonna start whipping it out and doing it too
Can you kill me too?
Didn't work now I shower
I want you to spank me. Oh, yeah, I can do that for you. Hold on. Let me get my crop out
Come on
Just wait till we get full body tracking. I'm just going to be like
Bop-bop-bop-bop-bop-bop-bop-bop
Tasty thing. Okay. Huh?
Where did you just try it?
Did you just stick your coochie in soy sauce?
Don't don't mess with your pH balance
I have another question, but it's also really spicy. I don't know how far you guys want to go with the spicy questions
Because that's what that's what my chat. That's all my chat's asking
But you do but you do why not like it. I don't care
There's my next question from chat
I'll delete the last one so that there's no proof at the same time at the same time. I would say three
Yeah, three. Yeah
toys
Oh, sorry. What was the question the question? Sorry. Uh, the question was what's your personal record for most toys?
Is used at the same time?
two four
Oh, I guess you could
Oh, I asked you could yeah technically one on one on each knob knobs, right mouth
You could use something
bottom
Nops upper bottom
copper bottom
Copper bottom
Is there is a freak?
Is there is like 16
It's like well actually
I put multiple in each hole
Then my hands get full
It's a lot of juggling
Every time I talk to these violour girls, I feel like I'm the most vanilla
And you can do that. That's okay. That's okay. You never put multiple bullets in
Multiple bullets. No, you have more than one
I'll do like actually then maybe mine would be four two because
Yeah, bullet
One hole second hole mouth hole
Yeah, my or or all in the same
You don't get curious. Come on. You got curious
Come on
I get curious. I just yeah
I like a little pain but
That's a lot
But the bullets
Azur when is gonna be your uh hentai tag to your list because I am in that chat. I am
Joining members
Um and to mercy for vanilla, honestly, I think it's hotter that you're vanilla because I just want to destroy you and corrupt you
Yeah, I want to show you so many terrible things. Oh show you the ropes
Mercy looks like
She doesn't want to be in a room with all of us
I want to be in the room with mercy. I can't wait to do an off collab
Because all this like the entire time just trying to get mercy to blush
Like immediately I'm still blushing since since you know, yeah
This is the start of the collab
I was I see and I'm scrawny we're here
I see like stop laughing that I fucking
Guy I mean can I do your voice guys? I can't believe you would ask that question. That's so in the profit
You want to know it's funny a lot of people thought that I see laughing during the our first collab on stranium
After they built they thought I see laughing was me. Yeah, that's right
I've seen a clip of that and they like
Tired of the laugh with your color
Yeah, they thought it was me laughing. That was not me. That was all I see the whole time
I
I still precious and innocent
If that corrupts her
The way she says her name is so cute too. She's like
They're really cute and every girl here is cute
Mm-hmm
Do you have any uh final questions? Yeah final final questions before final questions
Yeah, we're gonna go pop off after this
Yeah, I gotta go do my my monitor license
Azra we're very proud. Yeah, we're so happy everyone in vlr. Yeah
Now
Well something wholesome you enjoy spending time with the girls. Yeah, although this was not wholesome, but you know what I mean
I enjoyed it in a wholesome way
I do not get off at all in this street
No, I'm not of course. No, I felt like I felt like all of them have lied to me
Why?
I
They're all looking so suspicious
I was trying to look at you
Why are we looking like this? Why are we looking like this? Oh, we're just staring at you
I don't
Hawaii
What are you saying?
You say hawaii. She's a kawaii. I think oh kawaii. I thought you said hawaii
What is everybody?
It's not a question
All right, I guess that's it since you know you bitches don't have anything else to ask
You serious with the balls in the soy sauce thing. Yeah, did I fucking stutter?
do it
for science
and send
ball picks
I want to give me a question. I didn't see I'm so sorry
I listened to a couple of questions. I didn't see because I was fixing everything
Questions I I I just wanted everyone else to speak first and not take over
Interrupt me
Okay, well there was a tip that said what's everyone's favorite toy?
uh rose
Yeah, rose
The sucker
What about you mercy
Cute
The rabbit the rabbit. Oh
It's me. I'd be down there
She reads the rabbit
That's cute. I want to say the colors of us like pearl early
What does that say? I can't read. Oh
What does it say azura?
Which of your um, which of your avatars have the hottest blushing aggiel face? Oh, I
Let's all compare. Oh, wait, that's closer. Yeah, I mean
I mean, I kind of I kind of have like she has the whole nine yards
She has the the the panting. Yeah, this is mine
I
Like azuras because she's panting that's why I can I can get steam
There's a steam emo thing asset
Play we're trying this I'm gonna nuke this mod after oh my gosh
Oh
That's mine. I'm us all doing the oh wait. I needed to do heart heart eyes. There we go
Heart eye who just who just brought some fucking some steam into the into the
We've been a little bit of sweat
Hot
and then
Oh gosh, I can't do it. I can't I can't do it. I can't
This mod might have to be new
Oh my god
Thanks for coming to the orgy
Thanks for cumin
Hope you liked our little zatsu instead of doing uno because you know fucking suck. Oh
She's done
She's fucking heated herself into oblivion. Oh, she's back. There she is. Hold on. Let me welcome back mama
Oh my god, I like don't want to wait azura you're streaming right after this
Oh, we should all raid azura. Yeah, we all should raid azura. Okay. I'll set that up azura just end and go
Yeah, start your stream azura. Don't worry about it
Oh
Ah
Wait, she's gonna be ended stream, but she's gonna keep showing up for in our we got a kicker. Do we have to kick her?
She's gonna show up. Yeah, we got a kicker from the vtube studio. Azura leave the vtube studio room
She's can she hear us? What is she doing?
discord
Oh
Okay, I'll kick her from the room. I think I can do that. That's so funny
She this is her setting shit up
Okay, azura kick she's gone. Okay, she's gone now. I can move now. It's just us three while we wait for her to start
Let me move mercy. Oh perfect mercy moved herself. I moved myself. We're such a happy family
I
Show everybody the womb tattoo. Oh, oh, oh, we wire toes out
Wait, what?
My water my dogs are out. I'm so glad that the bottom half of everyone is like
Unseeable. I can walk around with emmy's model. This is great. Everybody enjoy
Are you showing everyone my feet? Who's the dad in this relationship? Yeah
The dad I feel like yeah, I wouldn't make a good dad
She'd be probably a great dad. Are you winning son?
Emmy's stomping on me and mercy's head. Ow. You guys are getting this for free. I'm giving you free speed
I'm more i'm slotting out my little sister
It's okay. I'll allow it
Yeah, I'm probably gonna nuke the bot. I'm sorry senpai. Is it that bad? Was it that bad? Should I nuke it too?
Are you worried about something? I'm not worried about
Yeah, getting
Getting the strike
Oh, you'll get a strike for that. You'll get a warning first before you get a strike. Yeah. Yeah
I'm not sure. I'm just like, oh
I'm also embarrassed embarrassed
That's because I said something
Oh, you didn't say anything bad
We all said worse things than you
Yeah, you're fine
If tell tell us next time because I do we don't want to make you uncomfortable. Yeah. Yeah
Oh, it's not uncomfortable. It's just that suddenly I'm just like, you know, and I'm like, yeah, and then afterwards you're like, oh
Understandable
Oh
It's okay
Don't nuke it. Everyone says don't nuke it
I always have to nuke my vods post stream clarity. So
Yeah, post stream clarity. You're like, I shouldn't have done that
You didn't say anything that you shouldn't tell at least in our our eyes. I don't think I said anything. I didn't
I didn't mean to say but at the same time. I'm at the at the same time. I'm just like, oh
She's got a little shy. She goes. Yeah, I'm getting a
Understandable
Where it's she opens up when we're around
And she's like, oh, no, I'm showing my hands to senpai
Okay, is this they're alive yet?
No, yeah, hurry up is her
Oh, I really mean you put the same meme
For the you we saw
Yeah
It's not coordinated
Same brain we hate like my gosh, I can't believe they said I'm gonna refund it. I'm gonna refund it
I'm gonna see if I can refund it. That's a good point. I'm gonna do that right now
I'll try
Uno that was that's a bummer. I really wanted to play uno. I know
Bummer, but like I can't believe it said you don't own uno
Managed played for 21 minutes, which is a fucking lie. How do I refund it? Do I have to uninstall it first?
you um, I don't I think you have to go through the
uh steam
Support thing and then be like this game did not fucking work. Yeah. Oh, I don't know how to do that
I think I think they have like instructions support
What do you need help with
uno
I want to permanently remove this game from my account settings
What?
No, I want to request a refund
Yeah, so we go to help steam support and then clip on where do I find help?
On the top left
Top left help. Oh help
steam support
uno
Um
Game player technical game player technical issue game doesn't start this game runs poorly
refund
A refund to people
Choose refund message. Please return to my paper. It'll also remove yours mercy
Yeah, it's fine. Okay
I don't know why it'll remove yours. What the heck? Okay, so don't worry about it. I think request
Okay, I did it. Yeah. Okay. I think it'll refund to zero's too. Yeah
There we go cool beans. Okay. She loves it. No
Oh, she is she is she is she is okay. She's live. Yes. Okay
Live from velour. It's Azura
All right
Go give her love. Please member
Give her everyone. She finally got membership. So this is her membership celebration. Yeah, give her you get a hand cam
Yeah, do you actually how exciting?
I'm gonna watch that. I'm gonna watch that too. I got a shower first, but then I'll watch I know I'm stinky
I'm stinky too. We got we got real stinky together here
Yeah, I'll I'll send everyone to there. Let me go edit all right
I'm gonna do my ending soon screen. Me too. Bye. Give me a second. Bye everyone
I touch you off before you kiss the viewer. Oh, no
You